tous les résidents sont dévastés
physiquement et psychologiquement on
n'est plus dans un lieu de vie on arrive
en prison
[Musique]
je vous invite à venir à l'ehpad
huguette valsecchi à paris 15 nous avons
interdiction d'accéder aux chambres de
nos parents depuis le 12 août
[Musique]
moi ma maman au premier confinement elle
a passé plus de trois mois enfermé dans
sa chambre de 15 mètres carrés sans
soins externalisée sens qui n'est si
elle n'avait pas ses soins de kiné elle
allait plus jamais marcher et finir
encore comme un légume finir sa vie sur
un lit à faire dans des couches je
refuse qu'elle perd toute sa qualité de
vie pour finir ses jours enfermée dans
quinze mètres carrés
[Musique]
nous notre directeur ne l'a pas présenté
nous n'avons pas pu en discuter
il ne l'a pas appliqué sur toute la
durée mais sinon il a maintenu les
interdictions d'accès aux chambres et
donc les interdictions de sortie
notre bras de fer il est face à ces
directions qui sont psychorigide
insensible j'allais dire lui-même
[Musique]
j'ai dit bonjour le toit une dame qui
mangeaient à la table de ma maman avant
elle m'a pas reconnue elle m'a regardé
bouche bée enfin vous sous verte les
yeux perdus dans le vide
moi j'ai quand même le papa d'une amie
son papa qui était très bien valide qui
sortait aujourd'hui pour des couches
il a tellement passé de temps enfermé il
a lâché la rue on a tué ces gens on a
tué le rat
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est que la somme il ya
bien sûr le résidant portent un masque
ou pas mais en tout cas la famille de
l'autre côté porte un masque
ils font tout pour qu'il y ait un
minimum de personnes de familles qu'ils
aillent en chant vous n'allez en chambre
je suis vraiment votre parent il est
tétraplégique en toute fin de vie
il est évident et qu' il doit y avoir
des familles qu'on pas respecté les
gestes barrière mais c'est évident mais
tout comme moi dans mon ipad
j'ai aussi vu du personnel qu'ils
respectaient pas faut arrêter de se
renvoyer la faute les uns sur les autres
[Musique]
on
il faut ramener de la vie dans les ehpad
1 ce qui vous tient en vie c'est la vie
c'est des gens que vous aimez
[Musique]